hi everyone I am Cecilia Martinez and
this is time travel debugging JavaScript
applications if you'd like to follow
along on the slides or save them for
later you can feel free to scan the QR
code or grab that URL I will also be
showing this again at the end of the
presentation so if you want to wait
until then to grab them feel free
so I am Cecilia Martinez you can find me
at ceciliacreates on Twitter or GitHub I
am currently a developer Advocate at a
company called ionic it is a open source
mobile SDK for web Developers
I have been very fortunate to be able to
actually work at a number of different
open source developer tools during my
career previously it was at Cyprus which
is a software testing automation
framework also at replay which is again
a free open source debugging tool that
we'll be talking about a lot today so I
am a unofficial Ambassador Community
Ambassador so to speak for all of those
tools and tweet about them quite a bit
and like to teach those in those areas
so here today talk to you about time
travel debugging specifically but before
we get into the future I'd like to start
by taking a look at the current state of
debugging
so developers spend a lot of time
debugging and by a lot I mean a lot like
everyone in this room probably feels
this as well but uh statistically we
actually spend up to half of their of
our time debugging and maintaining
software we talk about how developers
are more like mechanics just trying to
keep the car running versus Architects
building out new features and
functionality for their users
and debugging is complex and it's
complex because our applications have
become more complex I specifically work
with web applications and so I'm talking
about JavaScript applications today
specifically and we've seen a lot move
to the front of applications unless we
have handles on the back end so things
that are happening in the browser have
become more complex right so if you
think about an e-commerce app and an add
to cart button very simple functionality
you want to click the button and add an
item to a cart all of these things could
potentially take place in the flow of
your application from a single button
click so if you go to click add to cart
and nothing happens there's a lot of
area to cover when debugging you have
everything from your event listener and
handlers maybe you're setting a loading
State while you're checking your back
end setting off that API request maybe
you're updating a database to reduce the
amount of available in a in your in your
data maybe you're checking a third-party
micro service because it's actually
another vendor that provides that item
and coming all the way back to the front
handling the response and in your
loading State and finally updating the
Dom so again if something comes wrong
there's a lot of complexity that you
have to then debug
most developers that work with web
applications are also using Frameworks
so Frameworks like react angular and
view maybe you're using svelte or one of
the other new ones that are out there
these days those add additional
complexity so instead of our flow
looking like this it's actually more
like this because you have things
happening in between your application
where you're reacting or interacting
with the framework itself so for example
you may be to emit an event from that
button component up to a parent
component you may need to dispatch an
action to your state store in order to
update that loading State you may be
using a lifecycle hook in order to send
off that API request when that button
clicks so again these are all additional
things that could go wrong that you have
to then debug
so we're also limited with our current
debugging tools
show of hands who here has ever taught
how to debug somebody sat you down and
was like this is how you use debugging
tools this is how you should start when
something goes wrong
okay so those who raise their hands very
lucky I did not have that experience it
was very much a uh oh no something's
wrong there's no error message what do I
do now and a lot of trial and error and
learning how these tools work right and
a lot of times we'll know maybe one or
two functionalities within a developer
tool but not necessarily all of them and
you know there's some of us who may know
what a breakpoint does but not exactly
how to use it effectively
so if we take a look at a bug so this is
Excalibur it is a whiteboarding app it's
open source a developer tool and I use
it quite frequently and there is a we're
going to take a look at a bug that took
place in excalator
anybody here ever use Excel or Draw
before
yeah cool all right so again
whiteboarding tool you can type you can
draw shapes you can draw
and so in this bug specifically this is
a video of the bug when you have a shape
in this case a square and you resize it
down to zero eventually that shape locks
up and you can't resize it you can't
interact with it anymore
there is a link on the bottom if you
want to follow along with this replay
of the bug in order to see it but
essentially that's what we're dealing
with here and we can see visually on the
screen what's happening I was able to
record and reproduce this bug
so uh what are the ways that we could
approach debugging this with the tools
that we have right
so one of the first things that everyone
does is look for logs or error messages
in the console right and so
um this is what the console shows um in
the replay and the recording of the bug
that we have here uh so there's some
things here but related to analytics
couple warnings nothing specific to what
we're seeing on the screen and what's
related to our bug
so logs and error messages happen you
know you're reviewing them after the
fact after the bug has already occurred
so you can think of it like an informant
or like a man on the inside but it's
only helpful if he's if that person or
that log is at the right place at the
right time with good information and it
requires developers to anticipate where
things could go wrong so it requires us
to try and do some like scene into the
future and predict where errors might
occur and if I could predict where every
bug in my application would be I would
probably never have bugs again which is
not the case so
we can also use tools like live or
runtime debugging tools things that
allow us to inspect our application as
it's running so in browser developer
tools for example or in your IDE
developer tools you may have the ability
to inspect your HTML your CSS you can
also use framework developer tools for
react angular and view to inspect your
component props and State
but again all of these require you to
manually reproduce the bug and try and
catch that moment in time
so looking again at our resizing down to
zero I'd have to try and catch the
moment that the bug occurs once it hits
that point or I'd have to recreate it
over and over and over again so you know
if you think about live debugging as a
mechanic who like starts the engine and
then hits the gas pedal to see what's
happening in the engine as it's running
you'd have to start the engine and
reproduce that over and over and over
again to try and catch what's wrong and
inspect different things each time
So speaking of time what we're missing
is time the dimension of time and
debugging right so uh things don't
happen statically in our applications
things happen over periods of time
application renders event handlers
Network requests you know that go out
and then they get the response all of
these require time and happen over a
period of time traditional debuggers
only deal with one specific point in
time whether you're positive execution
from a breakpoint or you're reviewing it
after the fact
so usually this happens also after the
error has already occurred and you're
trying to piece together evidence after
the fact like a detective right
so that is where time travel debugging
comes in
time travel debugging allows you to
record and replay a trace of your
application execution
this gives you the ability to rewind
fast forward and pause at different
points of time in order to debug some of
you have may already used time travel
debuggers there are some like what I
would call full full functionality or
full-fledged time travel debuggers
there's one for Windows native there's
also some
udb by undo time travel debuggers for
any like GDB compliant or what's what's
the word compatible languages like C C
plus plus rust and go so those allow you
to record a trace of the execution
itself and then replay it in order to
debug it is um like you know performant
heavy at recording time but it captures
everything single thing that's happening
in the execution
you may have also seen some debugging
tools that have elements of time travel
in them one example is Cyprus a software
testing framework that allows has a
command log which essentially has every
single command that your test is
executing while it's while it's running
you can then go back and you can hover
over each command and the application
preview the the state on the right hand
side will update to show you what the
Dom looked like at that point in time
call that time travel that was actually
my first encounter with time travel
debugging
there's also a playwright another test
automation framework this one from
Microsoft that allows you to record a
trace of your test execution and then
view that Trace after the fact again it
records Network requests it also records
the actions that your test code is is
running and allows you to kind of jump
back and forth at those different points
in time
another one that you may have seen is
react Dev tools so Redux Dev tools again
as you're interacting with your
application records all of the
dispatches that are taking place and
allows you to jump and navigate back and
forth between those
uh so then there's replay so a replay is
a time travel debugger for the browser
and also for node this is the replay
browser I'm going to be focusing on web
applications today
um the replay browser essentially allows
you to start and stop a recording of
your application execution and then
create a shareable via URL replay of
that
so you're able to use that URL to attach
it to bug reports and to share with your
team in order to collaborate and have
the reproduction of the bug so you can
capture it once and it's reproducible
forever
so anybody who's ever worked on with
open source or on support teams I
started I started in technical support I
may have seen may have dealt with this
before where people want you to fix
issues but do not provide a reproduction
of that bug and makes it really really
difficult in order to understand what's
going on and fix it so with replay
you're able to have that recording of
what actually happened at that point in
time
the way that it works under the hood is
pretty complex effective it uses
essentially effective determinism so
this is essentially a replay is not
specifically deterministic we partially
record the low-level system interactions
that are taking place in order to
reconstruct them on demand in a virtual
environment when you replay so it's not
a full-fledged recording of what took
place it's a recording of enough
information to be able to literally
reconstruct that in a browser in a
virtual environment when you go to
replay it so we are able to essentially
reconstruct what would have been at that
point in time
by doing it this way if because
otherwise if you recorded everything it
becomes the overhead becomes too much
especially with a browser web
application to be able to replay
everything so if you want to know more
information about how that works
replay.io slash effective determinism
digs a little bit more into the
technology behind that and some examples
of how we debug our back end using
replay as well but essentially we're
able to simulate the world as it was
when the bug occurred so when we talk
about time travel debugging it's not
just traveling within time within the
recording of fast forward and replaying
you're literally traveling back in time
to when the bug occurred similar machine
similar operating system if we if the
bug took place at you know noon in Japan
the browser is going to think that same
exact situation is happening when it
replays the book
so this is an example of a replay this
is uh we The View we're looking at
earlier was a viewer mode which had a
nice big screen of the visual of what
was happening in the Dom it also has
debugging tools built in so you're able
to see all the source code that was
captured in the browser you have a
console you have your element react and
network inspectors and then you're also
able to scrub back and forth between the
execution of the code and you're even
able to add console logs retroactively
so if you didn't have a console log in
your code when before the bug occurred
you can go back and you can add one
after the fact and you can evaluate
variables at different point in time to
see what the value was before after
during the bug's execution
so it's almost like you become the time
traveler yourself and you're like oh I
wish I would have had a console log on
that line and instead of having to open
up your Dev environment recreate the
specific version of the code that is
that equals the bug code and then adding
that console login refreshing your
browser hoping it was the right spot and
it turns out it wasn't then you have to
like add another one and do console log
here here here one two three you can add
them retroactively within the replay
itself
so back to our Scala draw example this
is a replay of the bug and in our viewer
mode and this is a real bug I actually
like was able to reproduce it I
experienced it in excalibrol it was
already reported in GitHub and I was
kind of curious to see if I could debug
it I'm not was not familiar with the
code base at all but excalator is open
source and publishes its source Maps so
I was able to get in and see what was
happening
so using the built-in react Dev tools to
inspect I was able to kind of find some
context as to what was happening so I
found a resizing element property in the
react State and I could see that that
had some information about the square
that we were resizing the width I have
some X and Y values some scroll leg
scroll Y and also a scale X and scale y
value
so from there I searched just that kind
of resize function and found resize
single element this is all within the
replay I never pulled down the code base
and within that function I found that so
I found that resize single element
function and I was able to see that this
function executed 95 times in the
recording so this is where time travel
comes back in because we have a
recording over a period of time I can
get information about the code execution
during that period of time this helps me
to isolate where I want to dive in for
debugging
so I retroactively added a console log
to log the width of that element is the
value called element new width and I was
able to kind of zero in on moments we
got closer to zero and eventually it
hits Nan element new width becomes not a
number and it happens right after it
gets to zero so I was able to isolate
that point in time and that's where the
red line is we can see on the log there
this allows me to trace up the bug from
there
so I added another console log further
up where element new width is being
defined and I did it conditionally so I
really only care about once it gets
smaller so I said if element new if
element width is less than four then log
scale X because I could see that element
new width was being calculated based on
scale X going back to the point in time
where I'm locked in with that red line I
can see that after element new width
becomes zero scale X becomes negative
Infinity
that's a good sign we're getting closer
and once you're locked in on a point in
time you can even hover over the
variables in your code and see what the
value is at that point in time so here
I'm locked in at that moment where scale
X is negative infinity and I can see
that I'm calculating it by dividing by a
variable called bound's current width if
I hover over that variable it's zero
math does not like it when you divide by
zero and everything breaks after that
point so everything after that point
scale of X is negative infinity and
element new width is not a number and
we're no longer able to run that resize
function
so um because of this I was able to add
the replay to the GitHub issue I had
been stale for like almost a month and
they were able to push a fix the next
day so this is kind of an example of how
the time travel element allowed me to
really focus in on what was happening to
the specific code execution level and
Trace those variables back without
having to recreate everything and try to
add all those console logs manually
so with better debugging and better
debugging tools that allows us to better
understand our application again I was
not a scholar draw like contributor
before this I didn't know the code base
but I was able to learn it because I had
better debugging tools at my disposal
uh so uh Canada who's a software
engineer at replay he also wrote the
defensive determinism blog post about
how replay Works he said you know we
don't always understand all the possible
ways that the programs we have written
can execute when a program behaves in a
way we don't expect we're often at a
loss that we want to know why
so by seeing the application execution
over time we can see we can get a
clearer picture of what our application
actually does versus just what we think
it's going to do because those two
things like don't always line up
probably less often than we'd like right
so this lets us better understand our
app and how we can also identify
systemic causes of bugs
again the interesting thing about time
travel debugging specifically is that a
trace or a replay captures complex
information about our application
execution there's a lot of data in there
and we can use this data in a wide
variety of ways like debugging is just
the beginning it's just one application
of how we can use that information so
the replay protocol which is publicly
documented API that allows you to
interact with the information that's
recorded during a replay you can use
that in order to build out different
types of functionality so some examples
that we have is code coverage extraction
you know seeing what code run ran during
the replay in order to calculate how
much code actually executes in other
words react Mount detection you know are
you triggering too many component mounts
than you expect and you can use the
information that's recorded during a
replay in order to extract that and to
calculate that
um there's also information that you can
get about your automated test so replay
allows you to record your automated test
execution and if you think about that
you can over time understand uh when
test pass when tests fail and what has
changed within the context of that
execution
better debugging also leads to better
understanding of Frameworks I mentioned
earlier that Frameworks add complexity
to our applications and sometimes we
have to debug the framework not
necessarily our code but how we're
utilizing the framework right so going
back to our example of all the things
that happen in our application when you
think about what's happening underneath
the hood within view reactor angular it
really looks more like this right
because if something like goes wrong
with the framework that can be very very
difficult to debug you know you could
create a breakpoint in like the npm
package code and try and catch like when
it's rendering or with replay because
it's capturing everything inside the
browser you can actually inspect this is
an example it's the view recording or
recording of a view app you can actually
go in and you can see how view is
rendering elements so creating elements
based on your code so here I've added a
console log Within
runtimedom.esmbundler.js
for every single time that the create
element function is executing and I'm
logging the tag and the props that are
being passed through so if I if
something is an element's being created
in a way that I don't expect or maybe my
props aren't passing through correctly I
can actually go in I can make a
recording and I can debug the framework
itself to understand how it's
interpreting my code when it actually
goes to to render it onto the page
and then also so better debugging also
leads to better understanding of bug
patterns
there is a really great talk Jen
Creighton AKA girl coach the senior
software engineer at Netflix she gave a
talk on debugging async applications at
reactathon earlier this year you can
watch it on the YouTube link on the
screen but one slide that really stood
out to me or one point that she made is
the best debugging tool is knowing
something well a lot of times you don't
know something until you know it and the
more that you dig into your code when
debugging you can better Identify some
common patterns that can lead to bugs
some of these patterns are component
rendering just talked about that one
right understanding what triggers a
render if your component does not render
when you expect you may have stale State
you may update your state but the Dom
itself is still showing the Old State
because the component did not actually
trigger the render you can also have
performance issues if your components
render too many times I recorded a view
of the View application that I was
recording I showed earlier every single
time I clicked a plus one button on a
single card every single card on my page
re-rendered that's not performant I
don't want that to happen and I was able
to dig in more and understand why that
was occurring I was using the wrong type
of use an array instead of an object
that was basically what it came down to
another patterns that we see involve
state right multiple sources of Truth
accidental mutation and competing
dispatches of actions you know
originating commands from different
areas of the application that could
change state in ways we don't expect
and then we also have error handling
um I know that it's very difficult
whenever something goes wrong and the
console is beautiful and clean and
there's no help whatsoever there so uh
with JavaScript because the type of
language that it is and when you use
Frameworks we may not have conventions
for error handling and error reporting
or you may do it in ways the framework
doesn't recommend or it may not have
certain conventions depending on what
you're doing so another is passing
errors correctly from different areas of
your application so I have been
personally victimized by a okay status
Network request but then in the body
there's an error message right I don't
know if any of you ever seen that I've
seen it it hurts because I was like that
request is good that can't be the
problem it's got to be somewhere else
three hours later finally looked at the
end of the body and had to go take a nap
after that one so making sure that
you're passing errors correctly and
again utilizing the conventions the way
that they're supposed to be utilized
so let's take a look at another bug
resulting from one of the patterns that
we just talked about this is a bug in
replay itself so it is a replay of a
replay we can get some pretty serious
replay sessions I think I've been like
five levels down one time
um so if it's a little disorienting at
first that's that's okay it's just
because you're it's a lot going on here
again there's a URL if you want to be
able to follow along with this bug or
check out the replay itself
but what's happening here this is the
very first bug that I fixed on the
replay team and we have two ways to
toggle views one is that toggle menu up
in the right hand corner lets you go
back between View mode and Dev tools
mode that worked great there's also a
modal shortcut what we call the command
palette that allows you to switch views
using a keyboard shortcut and if you use
that method to change views then
everything the layout breaks we have an
extra column on the left hand side and
we have another row on top with
additional toggle and the share button
so it works one way does not work the
other way and again I wasn't super
familiar with the code base at the time
so I was trying to get my bearings in
there replay the devtools front end is a
react specifically an xjs app and it
uses Redux just to give you a little bit
of context of the code we're going to be
looking at
so I knew the bug didn't occur when we
used the toggle so I was like okay
what's the expected Behavior like what
do I what does it look like when it's
working and so I went into the view
toggle component and I found this handle
toggle function that had and we can see
towards the bottom here that it's kind
of um it's calling two functions set
selected primary panel and set View mode
and there is some logic that checks
whatever the current panel is and that's
panel refers to that left sidebar the
one that was breaking so this is what
working looks like I've got a little bit
of context and I'm able to see okay what
does it look like when it's not working
and I found this Anki down on the
command palette where we're executing
um execute command and I was able to
lock in at the one time that that
command ran and see that the active
index was zero and when we have an
active index of zero the First Command
that runs is open viewer so we're
executing an open viewer command and
that's the command that I'm running
whenever I'm selecting that open viewer
in my modal I could see that in the code
thanks to the recording
so next step is to see what happens in
that openviewer command so I found the
execute command and it says if key
equals open viewer we are dispatching
set View mode
has anybody already see what's missing
so this is the working code
so we're calling set View mode and we're
calling set selected primary panel
if we're doing it via the command
palette we're only dispatching set View
mode
and we also are missing the logic that
checks whatever the current panel is so
we have our updating from two different
places with two different sets of logic
and we're not doing the same thing each
time
so really what we need to do is have all
this take place within our our action
itself within Redux so every single time
that this executes we want to make that
logic check and we want to dispatch both
of those so the the fix was to move that
logic into set View mode and so now
we're no matter where the requests are
initiates we're always going to go
through the same logic and the same
state updates from one single location
so this is an example of that pattern we
talked about where you have competing
dispatches taking place one from a
component and then one from your Global
state
so really what I hope you take away from
this is to embrace bugs intentionally
with a learning mindset a lot of us
approach bugs with Dread and saying like
how am I going to get how am I going to
get through this but think about what
you can learn from your application as
you debug what you can learn about how
the framework that you're using as you
debug and then also what you can learn
about patterns as you're debugging
so some additional resources replayed
audio slash examples has a lot of
different examples of replays that have
real world debugging like the ones we
just walk through it also has some
general debugging resources Mark
Erickson is on the replay team he is a
core maintainer of Redux and talks a lot
about debugging with Redux Dev tools and
has some great resources on approaches
to debugging from a process perspective
I also have done nine talks this year on
debugging various different types of
applications so I have one on view have
one on angular have one in react have
one on cicd pipelines have one on just
uh Frameworks so if you have if any of
those situations apply specifically to
you you can check out those those are
all public and again you can follow me
on Twitter at Cecilia creates or on
GitHub I do talk about testing a lot
debugging documentation basically all
the things that developers hate doing
that's somehow might became my sweet
spot so feel free to reach out to me
there if you have any questions as well
and if you missed these links or any
others you can grab them all in the
slides so that QR code will take you to
these slides or you can also use the URL
so
great thank you uh so much I'm available
if anybody has any questions
yeah absolutely okay so
um what replay is doing is it's actually
an a runtime recorder at its core and it
has a replay protocol which essentially
is a bunch of commands that records the
interactions between your application
and the browser or your application
endnote so we do have some examples as
well of node we've seen people use the
node recorder to debug typescript for
example so they'll run the typescript
compiler in node and then record it and
we've had a few people fix bugs based on
that because they could see that it was
compiling to the wrong area
but um so it's partially deterministic
as I mentioned so we're not recording
every single thing that's happening in
order to be able to save that so what's
happened we're recording instead these
protocol commands and there's a large
API that essentially defines out all
these potential things that could happen
in those interactions between your
application and the browser so sometimes
we're getting paint points sometimes the
time to First paint all the network
request information the execution of the
code and we're capturing all of that in
a way that essentially turns it into a
first-class object so we're taking an
execution or An Occurrence of a runtime
and turning it into an object that has
all of those properties that are the
protocol API essentially and the values
for those properties across different
points in time then when we go to replay
it we actually have a virtual
environment where we have browsers that
are like it's it's kind of crazy
honestly it's like once I learned about
this I was like this is wild but if you
think about like you know how like
that's saying is if you have enough like
monkeys in a room with typewriters
eventually the right Shakespeare uh it's
like that so we literally are like
spinning up browsers and using the
information from that object to recreate
inside all of these browsers in a
virtual environment and enough and in a
way that's effectively deterministic so
uh we have like a joke that it's like
just enough uh deterministic or like I
can't believe it's not deterministic so
it's essentially deterministic enough
that for the end user it replicates that
experience of running the browser as it
did at that point in time and we have a
protocol viewer that you can actually
um
turn on like in your console that shows
all of the calls that are being made to
the protocol API while you're reviewing
your replay so we'll say like for this
point in time get the get the logs at
this point in time get the paints and
then if you were to go back and add a
console log we're literally sending that
message back we're saying update the
object as if there was a console log
here and then rerun it so we're
literally like re-executing the code
within that virtual environment in order
to add those console logs retroactively
so there's a lot of like wild like
devops actually happening because those
are all like virtual machines that are
being spun up and browsers that are
being spun up in those types of
environments and recently we made a
change the architecture where we allowed
a single replay to be split up across
multiple controllers that allowed us to
be able to record longer replays so
initially we like try to keep it less
than two minutes because like it became
like too performant or I'm sorry too
much overhead on the performance but now
that we're able to actually split that
across multiple controllers in our setup
we're able to have recordings up to 10
minutes now and we're hoping to be able
to get to the point where we have an
always-on mode for your node execution
so you can just continually record your
node and then when you encounter an
error you can go in you can pull that
time and you can start to debug from
there
yeah so it's because there's a lot more
happening than just the JavaScript right
so we're recording like all those paints
we're recording also the interactions
between like the react profiler and the
react Dev tools when we added redox Dev
tools there's like an experimental Redux
Dev tools as well that kind of like
broke things for a while and we had to
figure that out because when you think
about every single thing that's
happening in the browser it's not just
the JavaScript it's everything and the
paints like I'll be robbing all of those
Dom paints so it's not just if it was
just the JavaScript then I think it we
there are like time travel debuggers for
JavaScript there's one called wallaby I
think is the name of it and that is
perfectly
deterministic but because there's so
much more happening in the browser than
just that it becomes pretty much like it
breaks down if you try to be perfectly
deterministic they found so the team
behind this they started off with the
mosil at Mozilla they are the Firefox
Dev tools team so Jason Laster and Brian
is the are they the co-founders so they
kind of started there with firefox.com
and we're able to kind of bring it over
to replay to continue that work which is
also why a lot of it's open source
yeah so that's where the um that
protocol like examples repo those are
some of the things that we've like
sample in the theme team have like
thought of that you can do with it the
protocol API is like publicly documented
so anybody can we're hoping people will
take that and then run with it with
different ideas so replay does let you
record your test execution it works a
little bit better with Cypress because
the way that Cyprus works with the
iframe you actually are recording also
the test code execution in the browser
versus playwright that's happening um
underneath like you know before it
actually gets to the browser so we're
able to kind of show you all the test
code that executed as well to help you
debug so yeah so you could
so I don't know if anyone's used like
the Chrome devtools recorder yet we were
able to record like a user flow and then
convert that to Cypress or playwright
test code
um so you could kind of similarly
extract similar information from a
replay we haven't done that yet um but
that's something that we're hoping
people can jump on or give us like you
know feedback on what would be helpful
for that type of implementation
um so anything that runs in the browser
it can record so regardless of what the
framework is like what's framework
agnostic it just captures everything so
the thing that will make a difference
though is Source Maps so different
websites will publish Source Maps or not
if it's minimized code it's a lot harder
to debug I don't know if anyone's ever
looked at that before Jason can somehow
do it I think he's just looked at a lot
of a lot of code but one of the things
that you can do is you can also upload
Source maps to the replay servers so if
they're not published publicly we can
reference them when you do open a replay
so
yeah so um yeah so you so it's similarly
the node is via a CLI and it does have
to currently it does have to be like a
start and stop execution so you can't
like record something that's that's
always on like if you have a Dev server
up for example
um but it does the same thing it
generates a replay with all the code it
doesn't have a viewer there's no there's
no like there's nothing to look at but
it will record all the code execution
that you can then go in see how many
lines ran at those console logs after
the fact
that is experimental you know like I
said there's some quirks to it but we
have seen people use it for typescript
specifically because typescript is
another one of those things that
requires a lot of debugging sometimes so
okay and then I think we have time for
one more
um and so I will take you in the front
yeah so demonstrating diffs is a big one
so for example some people will use um
replays to document pull requests right
so they'll be like this is what it was
before this is what it was after
um and then you can like add comments or
you know function extract the
information of what was changed during
the code execution too so yeah so if if
there is something that's specific to
one Machine versus another you could
compare those again that's not
necessarily built-in functionality but
it's things like you can extract from
that information or go kind of go
hunting and add comments so
there's also a Discord replay.io slash
Discord that you can chat with the team
and share feedback and ask questions as
well so thank you so much I believe we
have to get the next speaker ready to go
but if anybody has any questions feel
free to come chat with me so awesome
thank you
[Applause]